ans mais c'est surtout à paul grimault
il faut bien dire que revient le mérite
d'avoir créé en france sinon une école
du moins un mouvement doté de toute une
série de films très brillant très riche
d'une grande délicatesse d'une grande
subtilité technique et visuelle
également qui engendra tout une fille à
son auteur dont aujourd'hui nous
récoltons maintenant tous les fruits
paul grimault bien vos films vos
premiers films date de 1937 et que
disons elysées vraiment pris leur essor
vers les années 40 41
vous avez participé aux groupes octobre
avec des gens comme prévert duhamel
brioude avec lesquels vous avez par la
suite collaboré oui c'est même si c'est
plus étendue que ça si beaucoup de
choses qui personnel d'amitié de chaleur
ça un jour disons que grâce à jean
aurenche les qui j'étais il m'a présenté
jacques prévert et puis depuis jacques
est devenu mon frère et pierre prévert
bien sûr aussi de s'affaler ils
s'étaient tenus alors que j'ai hâte rld
à bord et puis ensuite du cinéma c'est
ça c'est ça alors au début
au début c'était avec le groupe octobre
dont vous parlez tout de suite ça c'est
des souvenirs merveilleux tout ça j'ai
appris beaucoup de choses à denture on
s'amuse et enfin ont tous fermé après
exactement simplement
simplement je vous dis j'ai j'ai été
attiré par une forme de cinéma qui était
assez simple enfin je prenais pas ça
tellement au sérieux j'avais envie de
faire des films j'avais envie de les
faire d'une certaine façon
enfin je n'essayais pas de rentrer dans
un dans un cadre enfin dans une reliure
au départ je faisais les films que
j'avais envie de faire que je ne voyais
mais je ne voyais pas les autres les
faire à ma place j'ai vu des corps qui
s'étaient tous étaient 100 ans sans
grande ambition j'avais envie de faire
ces films plus que envie de travailler
dans le cinéma bris oui vous avez
pratiqué une animation qui n'était ni
une animation réaliste à la walt disney
ni une animation schématique à la
manière des tchèques par exemple non non
c'est bien deux choses d'abord c'était
pas le même genre d'histoire que je
racontais et puis aussi à cette période
de l'animation d'imation oui pour nous
mon frère nous cherchons nous chercher
la perfection la souplesse vont enfin vu
on voulait essayer de montrer qu'on
était capable de faire de l'animation
qui tournait bien faire qu'on puisse
dessiner sous tous les 1